today we're talking about machine images
deployment pipelines and the dashboard
API I'm reto Meier and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news compute engine now
offers machine images machine images
contain all of the instance
configurations and metadata feel virtual
machine that means creating backing up
and restoring virtual machines is easier
than ever even if you use custom images
because properties like machine type
network tags and labels and so on are
all captured in a single resource google
kubernetes engine just got an upgrade
with automated deployments that require
no management or updates the pipelines
are powered by cloud build and run
automatically when changes are made to
the source code you can even preview a
deployment from your pull request to
verify the change will work as expected
try it for yourself and let us know what
you think the cloud monitoring
dashboards API was released last month
to help you create dashboards
programmatically a practical use case
here is taking an existing dashboard and
using the API to recreate it across all
of your other workspaces and that's
exactly why one of our solutions
architects created this walkthrough
migrating a monolith is best done in
stages to see why that's true and how to
best move through those stages check out
this tutorial
it covers how to migrate using google
kubernetes engine from prep work to
dependency analysis to real-time
migration advice brought to you by your
get cooking in cloud hosts if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see the full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you